It's easy to put people in boxes.
There's us,...
...and there's them.
The high earners,...
...and those just getting by.
Those we trust,...
...and those we try to avoid.
The people from the countryside,...
...and those who've never seen a cow.
The religious,...
...and the self-confident.
There are those we share something with,...
...and those we don't share anything with.
And then suddenly, there's us:...
...we, who believe in life after death;...
...we, who've seen UFOs,...
...and all of us who love to dance.
We, who've been bullied...
...and we, who've bullied others.
We, who are brokenhearted.
We, who are madly in love.
We, who feel lonely.
We, who acknowledge the courage of others.
We, who have found the meaning of life,...
...and we, who have saved lives.
So maybe, there's more that brings us together than we think.